Ronald J post Reno is a senior fellow
with the Kirby Center Shipley chair in
the American Constitution an associate
professor of politics at Hillsdale
College Post reto earned his BA in
government magna [ __ ] laude at Claremont
McKenna College and his MA in politics
and PhD in political science at the
Claremont Graduate University his books
include American progressivism a reader
and Woodrow Wilson and the roots of
moderate modern liberalism post reto has
also written for The Wall Street Journal
and appears on the Fox News Channel
beginning in 2012 dr. Bruce Trudeau will
be the Dean of Hillsdale College
graduate school of statesmanship today
dr. post rito will be speaking on the
timely and pressing topic the Obama
administration versus the Constitution
please join me in welcoming dr. post
Rito
Thank You Katherine it's nice to come to
DC and see some of my CSIS my students
present and president former here and
some friends Ken and David good to see
you guys thanks to everybody for for
coming out this afternoon
I it's actually the second of these
first Friday talks that I've given I I
gave a talk at one of the very first
first principles on First Fridays that
was maybe a couple of years ago now it
doesn't seem like that long ago but that
was back when the Kirby Center was here
in DC sort of embodied in the in the
person of David Bob but wasn't actually
here in this marvelous
new facility so this is this is really
the way to do it it's a pleasure a
pleasure to be here of course much has
transpired since then and that's sort of
what my talk is about this afternoon
because indeed much has transpired that
seems to make it particularly
appropriate that we are here that the
college is here and has this enterprise
in DC dedicated to the study of the
Constitution and the principles of the
founding after all as I'm sure certainly
everybody in this town has noticed the
American Founding is very much back in
vogue these days in the debates here in
DC and of course I think throughout the
nation the debates we have about our
major issues in those debates in
addition to arguing about the pros and
the cons the policy arguments if you
will we are also talking about whether
the Constitution actually permits the
government to make the policy in the
first place that's kind of a novelty at
least in recent memory and and really I
should say that it's almost as much of a
novelty for conservatives as it has been
for liberals those those of you here who
maybe from the house side of the hill
even took the the trouble to undertake a
public reading
of the constitution at the outset of
this new Congress in January and I think
it was an important single signal that
Congress at least intends to abide by
the Charter that as we know is of course
the only legitimate source of its power
now among national elites and he
appeared not to be all that impressed by
this reading of the Constitution
although really my guess is with with
wide swaths of Obamacare now having been
declared unconstitutional by various
federal courts really they may be taking
constitutional questions I think a
little more seriously than they'd like
to light on but nonetheless the New York
Times called the houses reading of the
Constitution quote an empty gesture and
representative Jerry Nadler called it
quote total nonsense now unless we are
tempted to think in overly partisan
terms this disregard for the
Constitution has not I think we know
been the sole province of the left when
when for instance President Bush signed
the mccain-feingold campaign finance
restrictions into law he proclaimed that
while he thought they were probably
unconstitutional but he was probably he
was gonna sign them anyways and let the
courts figure it out this from somebody
again who swears to preserve protect and
defend the Constitution of the United
States so the point of that is to say
that it's a good thing I think that we
are starting to take the Constitution
more seriously in our national political
debates however having said something
about Congress the greatest threat the
constitutional government right now I
think isn't really taking place within
the debates in Congress as we've started
to see already I think the real action
over the next couple of years will be in
the bureaucracy as much if not more than
it will be in calm
Congress of course makes laws but over
the last century or so these laws have
been written in such a way and they have
been written so vaguely that the real
policymaking is done by the bureaucrats
and the agencies that have been created
to implement and to administer the
details of our laws the examples of this
scenario of this way of doing things are
abundant and I we don't need to look to
ancient history for them
indeed as many of you are no doubt aware
a certain elements of the current
Congress itself are now on the case as
the recent attempts for instance to rein
in the EPA I think have have
demonstrated the EPA of course is
presently in the process of issuing
final rules regulating greenhouse gas
emissions now due mostly to concerns
over the impact of these rules on the
economy you may recall that a similar
scheme of regulation garnered strong
bipartisan opposition in the last
Congress and failed to pass this was the
the the big environmental initiative
that did not make it make it through a
cap-and-trade I guess as what they were
calling it and you may in fact remember
that then then Senate candidate Joe
Manchin won election from West Virginia
due in part to a commercial which showed
him shooting a high-powered rifle
through the cap-and-trade legislation
right that the mats how unpopular this
was however in spite of this legislative
failure right in that assay in spite of
being rejected voted down by our elected
representatives these rules are right
now in the process of becoming law now
such a maneuvers possible of course
because when Congress enacted the Clean
Air Act and enacted its subsequent
amendments it defined the EPA's power in
such broad terms and in such vague terms
that it amounted to it essentially to a
delegation to the agency of the very
legislative power that the Constitution
reserves only for Congress a lot of
people blame the courts here and
certainly they they share their part of
the blame but it's also has a lot to do
with the way Congress wrote the law in
the first place in a similar example we
know that Congress in 2008 considered
and voted against taxpayer-funded
bailout of major American automobile
manufacturers nonetheless Treasury
Department proceeded to bail out both
General Motors and Chrysler
almost immediately after Congress voted
voted it down Treasury is able to do
this of course because the previously
enacted tarp bill Troubled Asset Relief
Program law supposedly passed for the
purpose of bailing out banks and other
financial service entities had been
written vaguely enough that the Treasury
Department had ample discretion to
divert funds to a wide array of entities
having little or nothing to do with the
financial services industry and if you
go ahead and look at that tarp law you
will you will see that they had enough
room to drive a truck through the same
kind of lawmaking by unelected
bureaucrats is of course a central piece
of Obamacare you may remember how the
former Speaker of the House responded to
those who are complaining that they
hadn't had a chance to actually read the
you know the the health care legislation
before they're asked to to vote on it
right and she said that well we first
had to pass the legislation so that we
could then learn what was in it now of
course you may have laughed may have
rolled your eyes you may have you know
put your foot through the television or
something like that however I hope you
can see sort of take from from what I'm
what I'm saying here that really that
was a perfectly truthful answer if this
extremely disturbing it was a perfectly
truthful and
the Obamacare legislation itself right
as long as it is couple thousand pages I
guess if I recall correctly actually
makes very little specific policy the
real decisions are delegated the
bureaucracy we've seen this in the in
the months since the passage of the
legislation in less than a year since
Obamacare has passed in fact the
Department of Health and Human Services
to whom most of this discretion is
delegated has issued a variety of rules
some these rules go as far as imposing a
ceiling on insurance industry profits
and de facto price controls on private
insurance premiums right a whole host of
very far-reaching policies that really
have been left up to the discretion of
the the unelected folks down at the
Department of Health and Human Services
and of course while Obamacare gets all
of the all of the attention those of you
who are involved in financial regulation
know that the dodd-frank financial
regulation bill may in fact be even more
sweeping in in just the sort of blank
check authority that it gives to
unelected bureaucrats to make rules
which are to have the force of law
dodd-frank is basically a tabula rasa
that the Wall Street Journal calculates
will require no fewer than 243 new rules
by 11 different agencies over the next
decade or so and I'm talking major rules
talk about a bill that you know that
first had to be passed before we could
find out what was in it we're going to
be finding out what's actually in
dodd-frank over the next 10 and 15 years
well there are a lot of these examples
as I as many of you know I could go on
all day I won't just one more you may
recall the union card check legislation
that was a big priority for the left in
the last Congress right this was to get
rid of the secret ballot in in Union
elections
that the union officials could tell who
was voting against organization and I'm
sure gently persuade them engage in
reasoned dialogue with these dissenters
but you may also recall of course that
this legislation failed to pass the last
Congress right again our elected
representatives did not enact it however
our unelected friends over at the
National Labor Relations Board but very
busy these days as we speak they are
busily hauling state governments into
court in order to overturn anti card
check legislation that has been enacted
by voters at the state level and now in
order to undo to attempt to undo the
right-to-work laws that exist in a lot
of the states if you seen the Boeing
Boeing case and what's going on in South
Carolina
well one final thing our our friends at
tiye our friends over at TSA by whom I
was groped just yesterday and my way
here especially since Washington has
taken the form of an armed camp this
week I've noticed it's amazing they they
really they're doing their part to
thwart the will of our elected national
legislature when Congress created the
TSA in response to 9/11 it put a
provision in the law that allowed TSA
functions to be carried out by private
companies and it's in fact a little
known fact that a few airports around
the country chose this option and have
been operating this way for years
however when interest in this private
option peeked over the recent complaints
about the TSA the unelected TSA
administrator issued a statement saying
that his agency would refuse as a matter
of policy to approve any more private
opt out applications from airports as a
matter of a matter of rule they wouldn't
even look at the specifics any longer so
the point the point of all of these
examples is simply to have you think
about the following question who is
really governing here who's making
policy is it our representatives in
Congress
who have to answer to us answer to their
constituents through elections or is it
bureaucratic administrators who aren't
elected and do most of whom have
guaranteed life tenure regardless of
whether or not you approve of the
policies they make every day now I'm not
going to shed a tear for Congress in all
of this as you know some kind of
innocent victim here
all right we know that the only reason
that bureaucrats exercise what amounts
to lawmaking power in this country is
precisely because Congress has given it
to them Congress can take it away
anytime it wishes and the reason it
hasn't done so at least until attempts
at these few recent exceptions it's very
simple right under the current
arrangement that we have that I've just
been giving you examples of members of
Congress are able to take credit they
take credit for enacting vague and nice
sounding platitudes into law so we enact
things like you know we mandate that
there's going to be clean air or we make
enact a mandate that universal
affordable health care for everybody
right as if right that can be done at
the wave of a wand or the snap of one's
fingers right who's against those things
after all and then of course when it
comes down to actually making the tough
policies the actual laws that cost
people their jobs that cost our economy
its productivity where you have costs
and benefits to weigh in real winners
and losers who have to be identified
because the power the government's going
to be going to be put to use
well then congressmen have been
perfectly happy to let members of the
bureaucracy make these difficult choices
for them someone else therefore is to
blame and then of course I mean is
everybody in this town knows then they
really pour it on right they have
oversight hearings and they haul the
hapless bureaucrat up before the
congressional committee and the rate
said hapless burek
at four doing all of these awful things
and enacting all these awful policies
which of course Congress itself has
empowered a Hutt empiric rats to make in
the first place and it's a big game and
it's a big theater again hard not to
laugh at that and of course it would be
funny if it were about some other
country as I've spoken to groups of
concerned citizens over the last couple
of years to me it's it's become very
evident that this situation has people
profoundly concerned and many of these
people have not been politically active
until recently and when you know the
last couple of years have really been a
kind of revelation to a lot of them what
has people most concerned I believe as
demonstrated by some of these examples
that I've been talking about is the fear
that they have that they may be losing
the ability to change things through
election that elections no longer matter
that with the administrative state that
we have with Congress passing laws in a
way that hardly makes it accountable for
their consequences we're really losing
our grip on representative government in
this country now add to that a related
problem which I think also rises from
the growth of the administrative state
and it's a phenomenon again I want it
best I think I can best illustrate by
way of example earlier this spring we
learned of many companies many
organizations being granted waivers from
certain requirements of Obamacare it
really was quite remarkable just how
many of these were being handed out last
I recall the Department of Health and
Human Services had granted over a
thousand of these although there may
well be folks in this audience who have
more updated figures than that and who
know more about it than I do
but that was just the last time I looked
and of course given the massive burdens
and the massive costs of Obamacare
it certainly shouldn't be surprising
that people want to be exempted sure
wish I could be exempted what is a
little shocking is that the folks being
granted waivers from the law are in many
cases the very same folks who lobbied so
hard for the law's passage just a random
example our friends at the Service
Employees International Union SEIU get
the award for a particularly high degree
of shamelessness as they lobbied hard
against the repeal of Obamacare in the
Senate earlier this year at the very
same time at the very same time that
different organizations within the SEIU
were receiving waivers because they
didn't want to be subject to Obamacare
as onerous regulations at the same time
again you might be asking yourself how
do I get one of these waivers this would
be great if they're handing out so many
where is the line well certainly being
in the favor of the Obama administration
bureaucrats who administer the law would
be a good first step
Hillsdale College will not be getting
any of these waivers anytime soon I'm
quite confident of that the point is is
this is this the rule of law where
everybody is treated equally under the
law or is it the rule by favor of the
crown were those in good standing
receive special treatment another
example this problem I've already
mentioned the bailout of General Motors
some of you may also recall that this
bailout was undertaken on the basis of
what I think has to be the most
egregious violation of the rule of law
I've seen in my lifetime turns out of
course GM had borrowed a lot of money I
was having a little trouble paying back
good chunk of that money was owed to
secured bondholders many of these were
pension funds who were making
investments on behalf of retired
teachers and police officers just
average people and these people loaned
their money
because under the clear terms of the law
they would be first in line to be repaid
in the event of a bankruptcy that is the
law of land problem was if that law was
followed in GM's case it would mean that
these secured bondholders would be paid
and that the generous contracts held by
the United Auto Workers Union which by
clear law come last in line they would
be in jeopardy
well the Obama Treasury Department
wasn't wasn't about to let that happen
and so through through various
strong-arm tactics through really you
know name-calling against these you know
high-rolling finance seers you know that
is to say the representing the average
people and their in their pension funds
through these kinds of tactics the law
was simply set aside and was set aside
to favor these friends of the government
and it was done at the expense of those
who didn't have such powerful friends
now these are not further attempts on my
part to to depress or enrage you it's a
case maybe but rather I point to them by
way of contrast to make a point about
the virtues of our constitutional system
our Constitution and the system of the
rule of law that it established has
until recently been the envy of the
world and if we reflect on the
principles of our founding we can see
the wisdom of our constitutional
framework our founders understood that
there are essentially two ways in which
government can exercise its authority
the first of these is a system of
arbitrary rule that's one where the
government decides how to act on an on
an ad hoc basis granting decision-making
power to the whim of whatever official
or officials happen to be in charge
relying on the expert judgment of these
officials they know best they've got the
education they've got the training they
have the prudence and so on the second
way forgot
to exercise its authority is to
implement a system grounded in the rule
of law and it's it is a wonder that in
this day and age one actually has to go
back and define and I find this all the
time for my students I have to define
what the rule of law means because it's
been so taken for granted in this
country that we're on the brink of
losing it in this system of the rule of
law legal rules are made in advance
they're published
they bind both government and citizens
and they allow the citizens to know
exactly what they have to do or not do
as the case may be in order to avoid the
course of authority of the government so
the founders implemented this rule of
law system they did it partly out of
reaction to the schemes favored by the
likes of Massachusetts Governor John
Winthrop in the early years of
Puritanism in the United States
Winthrop believed of course that
government policy ought to depend upon
the wisdom of the government official
under such under a system like this
where the wisdom of the magistrate is to
govern no one knows for sure what the
rules are no one knows what the
penalties are for violating the rules
nothing except the good will of the
magistrate keeps the government from
acting according to a whimsy or
dictatorial willfulness and so against
this scenario I think the advantages of
the founders rule of law system are
perfectly evident first thing is that
the rule of law facilitates government
by the consent of the governed rules are
made in advance they apply to a broad
array of cases that may arise in the
future and thus the people have the
opportunity to consent by way of
deliberation and by way of the votes of
their elected representatives in a
situation where ad-hoc decision-making
is used a decision is made only once
once a particular case arises provides
no opportunity for the citizens to
deliberate and to consent a second
advantage of the system apropos of that
the cases I've been referring to
is that it makes it much more difficult
for government to play favorites to
benefit its personal friends to harm its
personal enemies you may have noticed
the news recently that the Obama
administration intends to issue an
executive order where it will want to
know about the political donations of
those who are being considered for
federal contracts just for
record-keeping mind you that's why the
rule of law system is the best means of
maintaining a government dedicated to
the equal protection of its citizens
rights which is of course the aim and
the goal of all legitimate government as
the American Declaration of Independence
tells us so in order to secure
individual rights in a system that it's
based upon the rule of law we know that
the founders instituted a constitution
designed around a separation of powers
model under this model the legitimate
authority of the government is exercised
by three co-equal departments of
government each making sure that the
others remain in their proper place
fundamental aim here is to safeguard
rights against the possibility of
arbitrary government in fact James
Madison in Federalist number 47
redefines the word tyranny to mean the
absence in government of the separation
of powers when you don't have separation
of powers you've got tyranny and of
course when he when he made that point
he was simply quoting from Jefferson and
Jefferson's notes in the state of
Virginia now it's from this fundamental
aim of separation of powers the same to
protect individual liberty that we can
discern I think three important tenets
three important principles of the
American Constitution that bear directly
on the situation with the administrative
state today of the spy no means an
exhaustive list but but I think it gets
to the heart of the problem the first
would be the principle of what's called
non delegation if this if the separation
of powers means anything at all it means
that one branch of government may not
permit its powers to be exercised
substantially by another branch
pretty straight for if you have that you
don't know separation of powers right
second principle corollary the first no
combination of powers within a single
branch here again
Madison quoting Jefferson in the
Federalist Papers says the following the
accumulation of all powers legislative
executive and judiciary in the same
hands may justly be pronounced the very
definition of tyranny so under the
second principle of separation of powers
tenet vital to maintaining the rule of
law those making the law must also be
subject to that law being enforced upon
them in the same way as everybody else
line independent authority those
involved in the execution of the law
don't get to write it first before they
enforce it they don't get to make it up
as they go along
instead they have to enforce laws that
have been previously established by
separate Authority in other words when
HHS goes about enforcing Obamacare it
shouldn't get to write the rules first
before it enforces them and finally
under this principle separation of
powers those on whom the law is enforced
have their cases judged by an authority
entirely separate from the hands that
bring the prosecution and this is
elemental American civics third ten of
the separation of powers responsibility
of administration to a popularly elected
executive the government remains wholly
popular to use the phrase of Federalist
number fourteen because those who carry
out the law the administrators as we
call them today the bureaucrats they are
directly answerable to the president
who's elected remember the Constitution
grants all of the executive power and
Article two to the president and it
requires that the president take care
that the laws be faithfully executed so
administration as powerful as even some
of our founders surely envisioned it but
administration was placed wholly within
a single branch of government clear line
of political accountability for
administrators is established that way
so that when they exercise power it
takes place only within the confines of
law only within the confines of popular
consent now for those of us who think
that these principles make a certain
amount of sense who are who are
concerned with really restoring the
Constitution to its full authority in
our government need to look very
carefully at how the administrative
state functions today and the best way
to think about it seems to me is to
contrast these principles I've just
outlined with some basic facts about the
way that bureaucracies exercise power
first there is the basic and unavoidable
fact that the administrative state today
is built on governance by expertise at
the expense of governance by consent and
nowhere is this more evident than in the
abandonment of what I have called non
delegation which abandonment is the
pillar of the administrative state today
the thing without which it could not
exist as I've tried to show in these
examples it has become standard practice
for Congress to pass extremely broad and
vague political goals to call that law
and to delegate to administrative
agencies that is to say to the executive
branch the responsibility of coming up
with the actual law with a specific
policies required to achieve these broad
goals a great historical example here is
a lawn Act the law enacted by Congress
back in the 1930s to establish and
empower the Securities and Exchange
Commission in laying out their what is
supposed to be a specific policy for the
SEC to enforce this is what Congress
says in the law quote the Commission
shall make regulations that are in the
public interest end quote
decide an even better example in the
legislation on broadcast licenses
consider how specific Congress was in
writing the law that empowers the
Federal Communications Commission it
directs the FCC to quote grant licenses
if public convenience interest or
necessity shall be served thereby end
quote
who determines what exactly is
convenient what exactly is in the
public's interest is it Congress who
actually has to be accountable to voters
for representing that interest or is it
the bureaucracy which has no
accountability to the people whose
interest it is asked to represent in
these laws second major inconsistency is
the undermining of separation of powers
by the combination of powers within
single agencies and here it's it's a
slightly more complicated scenario than
I have the time to describe because
there are different different kinds of
agencies and you know in the federal
government some are more independent
than others okay so with that caveat but
here there's a legal scholar who has
done excellent work on this a fellow by
the name of Gary Lawson and he's
especially looked at the independent
agencies that make a lot of policy in
our national government and I I have a
favorite quote from him that I like to
read and and I'll indulge myself again
because it's a very accurate account of
how the Federal Trade Commission works
today in fact them here might hear with
my son getting in a little serve
educational tour of Washington while
while I'm here for the lecture we walked
by the FTC today and I'm I'm going up
and down Constitution Avenue explaining
which agencies are constitutional and
which one which ones aren't so we went
by the FTC and I had to put the quote in
my speech but this is Lawson apropos of
the idea that you can't you know you
can't combine functions in a single set
of hands that this goes to the very
bedrock of our of our constitutional
principle says Lawson's account he's a
lawyer he knows what he's talking about
how the FTC operates quote the Federal
Trade Commission promulgates substantive
rules of conduct means it makes laws the
Commission then considers whether to
authorize investigations into whether
Commission's rules have been violated if
the Commission authorizes an
investigation the investigation is
conducted by the Commission which
reports its findings to the Commission
if the Commission thinks that the
Commission's findings warrant an
enforcement action the Commission issues
a complaint the Commission's complaint
that a Commission's rule has been via
than prosecuted by the Commission
judicata by the Commission
okay now the Commission adjudication can
either take place before the full
commission or or before a
semi-autonomous administrative law judge
if the Commission chooses to adjudicate
before an administrative law judge
rather than before the Commission and
the decision is adverse to the
Commission the Commission can appeal to
the Commission that that is exactly how
the FTC operates is exactly how a lot of
our independent agencies operate when
they make policy it's not an exaggerated
account of the agency's decision-making
process finally as a third major
inconsistency I would point to the
weakening in today's administrative
state of the political accountability of
administrators and the shielding of
large subsets of agencies from real
political control now as I've said given
the complicated structure of the
executive branch some agencies are more
independent than others of course even
with the existence of the civil service
system it is nonetheless a fact that
federal courts have recognized the power
of Congress to create agencies
presumably that are they're part of the
executive branch where else
constitutionally could they be after all
but that are nonetheless shielded from
direct presidential control can scratch
your head how are you in the executive
branch if you're not controlled by the
president who's given all the executive
power not quite sure how that works
check out some Supreme Court decisions
back from the 1930s if you're interested
in the kind of tortured logic normally
the shielding is accomplished by
limiting the president's freedom to
remove agency personnel hmm now these
rulings reflect the acceptance of a key
tenet of progressive administrative
theory that is say that many areas of
administration are based on expertise
they're based on neutral principles they
must therefore be freed from the
influence of politics and electoral
accountability so these are all
inconsistencies one might even say
fundamental differences between the
founders
constitutionalism and the principles of
our administrative state today right now
if I were here to give you a different
talk or if I were giving the talk I
think that I gave a couple of years ago
when I when I was here I would launch
into an historical explanation of how
the move from the principles of the
founding to the modern administrative
state occurred but but that I think
certainly would be overstaying my
welcome here but the the very short
version of that is is that the
progressive movement which of course
came to its height at the turn of the
20th century in America really became
impatient with the limits that were
imposed on the federal government by the
Constitution you want to see the
personification of that impatience in a
sea Teddy Roosevelt in order to handle
the the vast array of the new
redistributive and regulatory powers
that the progressives had in mind for
the national government it was necessary
to erode these constitutional limits and
it was also necessary to come up with an
administrative system that was capable
of managing the whole new set of
responsibilities the whole new set of
federal programs and endeavors that the
progressives had in mind so it shouldn't
surprise us that those calling
themselves progressives today remain
strongly attached to the kind of
discretionary expert governance that was
lodged by their ancestors in the
original progressive movement as I said
that's really a story for another day or
a story that I've already told let me
finish with this because I think it's
important if we are to reflect on our
responsibilities as citizens within a
constitutional republic I said a few
moments ago that separation of powers
was key for the founders because among
other things those making the law
wouldn't be the same as those enforcing
it
the point of this of course is to make
sure that those making the laws will do
so with the knowledge again that they
themselves they themselves will also be
subject to that law and will have it
enforced
on them equally mine and partial
authority right that is a bedrock
protection of the people's liberties so
reflect on on that for a moment and then
reflect on the following fact because
members of Congress have their health
care paid for by the American taxpayer
they in fact will be shielded from the
worst effects of the so-called health
care exchanges into which all of us are
going to be thrown now well it's not
quite right to say that Congress is
exempted from Obamacare that's not the
case although maybe if it's nice to HHS
it can get a waiver I didn't you know
but it is the case that it will not feel
its burdens in the way that the most
most of the rest of us will reflect to
on the waivers being granted from this
law to those who hold the favor of the
government and reflect finally on this
passage written by James Madison in the
57th Federalist paper that's what
Madison wrote quote if it be asked what
is to restrain the House of
Representatives from making legal
discriminations in favor of themselves
and a particular class of society I
answer the genius of the whole system
the nature of just and constitutional
laws and above all the vigilant and
manly spirit with which actuates the
people of America a spirit which
nourishes freedom and in return is
nourished by it if this spirit shall
ever be so far debased as to tolerate a
law not obligatory on the legislature as
well as on the people then the people
will be prepared to tolerate anything
but Liberty so are we in America ready
to display what Madison called our manly
and vigilant spirit which he said
nourishes freedom or are we instead
prepared to tolerate anything but
Liberty I think we're in the process of
answering that question in American
politics right now I think the next few
years in American politics
go a long way to answering that question
so let me conclude with that thank you
for your your patience your endurance
and I would be happy to take any any
questions that you might have I'm told
I'm running my own Q&A period here so
who's up yes ma'am we talk a lot about
the lack of constitutionality and a lot
of the things that President Obama is
doing where do you see the fight
beginning if if it can be done in in the
branches of government where where do we
begin the fight which one do we take
over first in order to really turn
things around and go back to a
constitutional system because I feel
like this is ahead with 10,000 snakes
and you don't know where to start in
order to yeah well I mean I you know I
think that the first step the first
essential step was taken in 2010 in in
the midterm elections and and by that I
mean that the solution is a it's a
political solution it has to be
that's what Madison you know means in
that passage you know if the people
themselves can't you know elect
representatives who are who are going to
protect their liberties that they can't
be vigilant about that
you know then then we're lost and and
there's there's a tendency and I mean I
I highly sympathize with it you know
maybe the Supreme Court or maybe the
courts will come in and they'll the
march in and they'll save us you know
they'll take the Constitution and use it
like a hammer on these on these guys
who've enacted all these laws that we
think are unconstitutional Obamacare the
obvious one you everyone's you gosh
maybe the only and we can get five votes
and you know we won't have that you know
there may be some victories that come
that way you know short short term
you know you get enough judges together
or something but but in the end I mean
it seems to me that that the judiciary
is going to go as as politics go I mean
that's always the case and and
furthermore Congress really is in
control of this you know it's it the
administrative state is created by
Congress it is nourished by it's funded
by Congress its authority comes from
Congress and so I think you know the way
to start is is it's encouraging to see
some of the attempts to take back
authority from agencies like EPA I think
there's going to be some run on NLRB my
guess is and and these arguments are
starting to resonate you here you see
floor speeches you know where the
Constitution is referenced I this is
arguments about delegation these these
things these arguments have not been
raised you know I mean I don't know when
the last time they were they were raised
and in fact many on the right has made
their made their peace with with some
constitutional you know sort of blind
eye toward this kind of delegation so
you know that that's where it had that's
where it has to start there there was a
lot of it seems to me measures
percolating in Congress which are going
in this direction obviously you know
more you know more is needed
those aren't probably going to go
anywhere if you don't have a president
who's going to sign them I mean that's
that's an obvious fact so but but that's
where you start Congress Congress
created this Congress has the power with
a stroke of a pen literally with a
stroke of a pen to to undo it or I mean
let's be realistic to start you know
peeling back a little bit right so
that's that's where you start all right
so so you do what you did in 2010 you
know get out there get good candidates
get them get them elected keep keep the
keep the pressure on those who are
elected you know not to get comfortable
with the situation that's been created
let people know that they're being
watched you know that's it just read was
it where was it it was somewhere this
morning I read
that Senator Snowe is she filibustered
her own small business bill because the
you know they weren't going to allow a
vote on I'm probably botching this
there's probably sure there's someone
from the Senate here but you know they
weren't going to allow a vote on this
amendment which is going to rein in some
of the authority of some agency I think
the EPA so you know even why because
she's guarded got a challenger probably
she's going to get so that that's how
this is done yes ma'am the president to
write executive orders yeah the question
was you know it I think it is is there a
kind of tension between executive orders
and and if you're sort of restore non
delegation yes and you know the
president has given a lot of
responsibility constant constitutionally
and he's given and and Congress
constitutionally grants the executive
you know power to and the Constitution
says article two he has to take care of
the laws be faithfully executed in other
words in order for the for the president
to carry out his constitutional
responsibilities he's going to issue
orders he has to have people that work
for them he has to tell them what to do
he has to establish policies within the
executive branch so I'm not arguing you
know by any means that the president you
know can't or shouldn't be able to to
make orders governing his own branch
within the confines that the
Constitution gives to his branch so that
is you the question is not so much the
executive orders right but their scope
so do they do the executive orders take
the place of law you know are they are
they executing law or are they are they
making law and that's that's the
difference and when the you know when
when the courts have considered this
delegation question what they look at is
you know what does it mean to make a law
how specific does Congress have to get
in setting the policy
right when does it become Congress or so
vague that it's just uh hey you you
figure it out and that's where the the
argument and seems to me that's where
you have to deliberate about about the
line being drawn and and this isn't
about by the way getting at getting a
puny or kind of impotent executive not
not at all we know that many of our
founders of energy and the executive is
a leading character in the definition of
good government that's that's Hamilton
from Federalist seventy they were they
we needed a vigorous administration one
of the problems are the Articles of
Confederation
so let's you know let's not you know
sort of think that the idea here is to
have a kind of minimalist sort of system
as appealing as that sounds given you
know given some of the policies these
days but rather it's to have a powerful
government when it needs to be powerful
within constitutional limits I mean that
that's that's that's an important
distinction you won't follow up yeah
well Congress has the power to make law
and to the extent that you know
executive or you know the executive
orders purport to make law presumably
Congress would have something to say
about this part of this is what is part
of the healthy tension of course that
exists between you know the the
legislative and executive branch the
problem is when the legislative branch
has an interest in in giving its power
away all right because that's a frequent
question I get what doesn't seem that
seems kind of contrary human nature that
you give away power well because it's
part of the game of being able to
maintain your pay power and prestige you
get the you give away the blame you take
the credit I mean that's that's that's
how that works so the incentives are
slightly you know sort of messed up and
the way things are done right now you're
okay I'm going over here then I'll come
back over here um dr. booth street oh I
have a online question Chelsea from
Dallas Texas asks I've heard a lot about
a lot of people complain about the
president's use of czars I'm not
convinced that they're that bad since
they're directly controlled by the
president do you feel that they might
actually be more useful and more
constitutional than regulatory agencies
yeah well that
a perceptive question I usually get in
trouble in front of conservative
audiences because I think to a certain
extent I think that the czar this our
system is as much ado about nothing I
mean that that is to say if it's the
case right if you know what what's the
best argument to be made
constitutionally for Tsar's
okay you have parts of the
administrative state let's let's take
transportation policy for example just
to pick one randomly and you could have
ten different agencies that are involved
in implementing transportation policy
okay
is it really constitutionally
problematic for the president to have
somebody who answers to him who's close
to him was in his White House office and
to say you know you're gonna be in
charge of coordinating and overseeing
the various agencies as they implement
transportation policy because I want to
make sure that transportation policy in
this administration is carried out in
accord with my wishes because by the way
I'm the only one who gets voted for
around here I'm the elected
representative and so partly the czar
system and this is not novel to
President Obama this goes way by
President Nixon was one of the first to
try to reach out and control more of the
administrative state in in a manner that
was closer to him more politically
accountable to him that's one of the
reasons why he was absolutely hated you
know there's a lot a lot of reasons why
I mean that certainly is one a lot of
people don't understand that so in that
respect there is a there actually is a
constitutional argument to made on
behalf of czars now the problems you
know come with you the fact that they
exist without you know Senate
confirmation and all of that there are a
host of constitutional issues that do
arise yeah I agree with that but it
seems to me that that's kind of a
bizarre system is kind of a red herring
the fact is why does the administers the
administration have this power delegated
it to be to begin with it's really the
delegation issue I think more than is
our issue I think I promised to go over
here hi my name is Amanda
next and I currently intern on the hill
and I noticed that with recent elections
a lot of people got voted into office on
the promise that they were gonna make
sure that new laws cited the
constitutional authority to them I
haven't really seen that occur and I
just want to know what is your take do
you think that that's just for show or
can this be something really useful to
kind of hold some of these elected
officials accountable and make sure that
we are creating laws that are compliant
with the Constitution yeah I think
certainly of course it seems to be
entirely appropriate that legislators
who take an oath you know to uphold the
Constitution mclecklin and should have
to reflect in a very direct and specific
way on where they draw the authority to
enact the policy that they are you know
purporting to enact so that that seems
to me to be a perfectly sound the
problem is of course that you know
people can be very clever about taking
the words of the Constitution and
twisting their plain meaning or they can
take advantage of clauses in the
Constitution that don't seem to be quite
so specific so in problem is in practice
if you don't have legislators who take
to this task honestly and forthrightly
it become simply as well it's kind of
paperwork you know requirement so let's
get the you know box well you know you
know interstate commerce let's check
that one or let's check the general
welfare that's always useful let's check
that one and so it becomes a kind of you
know as a practical matter it becomes a
kind of you know as you say for show
part of the part of the problem here is
of course that again to reflect on the
words of Madison you the people
themselves have to maintain a vigilance
over how their government actually
interprets the Constitution and this
this applies not just the legislators
but but even to the courts right the
courts have been a been a partner
you know certainly with the growth of
progressivism in the in the 20th century
to basically take the plain meaning the
Constitution in certain cases turn turn
it on its head so that's why as a
practical matter these sort of mandates
to cite constitutional authority which
I'm all in favor of in fact kind of
falter if legislators aren't held
accountable right if people aren't
vigilant about their liberty I mean and
that's the thing it's important to make
the following point there's a temptation
we have and it's an entirely you know I
think reasonable one an understandable
one is a temptation we have to look at
the Constitution as a kind of fix all as
a kind of you know cudgel if we could
just take that Constitution and hammer
people with it you know that that's
that's what we need to do but what
Madison is really saying in that in that
document is what matters more are the
people themselves okay so if you have a
constitution it could have the clearest
protection for liberty it could be the
best Constitution written but but the
Constitution's
puts in place a series of arrangements
which the Federalist Papers refer to as
auxiliary precautions they say thing you
know they're they're kind of a back-up
plan what's the primary precaution
it's the vigilance of the people right
if you have a people who are corrupt if
you have a people who are completely
dependent who are who are you know
slavish to to an administrative state
who want to be taken care of instead of
wanting to take care of themselves if
you have that you know Constitution a
constitution handed down from God
directly would not save such a people
and so that's to go back to the my
answer the previous question it really
is the people themselves who have to be
vigilant about this or we are done for
I'm told I can take one more question so
where am I taking it from okay yes ma'am
I just do as I'm told so
Alyson Miller he was slavish attitude
yes thank you for your talk Alice and
Miller from the Heritage Foundation I
realized there's a lot of culpability to
be spread around with the expansion of
the administrative state but could you
pinpoint I guess the Congress perhaps so
the moment in history I mean was it was
it during the Wilson administration when
the administrative state really I mean
maybe the floodgates didn't open but the
trickle started you know okay so she's
given me entree with that question to
give my earlier lecture about the
progressives so about an hour if you
have about an hour we'll go you know let
me give the one-minute version to the
extent that I'm able the you look the
modern administrative state is certainly
built on the New Deal because once you
have you know the policies that you that
you get you know coming out of the New
Deal you needed an administrative
apparatus to implement them and in fact
you know I've done some studying of the
design of the agencies how how is the
sec created you know how how are these
agencies alphabet soup agencies created
in the New Deal and there's a lot of
turns out a lot of progressive influence
so those like for example James Landis
who was Franklin Roosevelt's can
right-hand man the architect of the
design of these administrative agencies
in a huge advocate of the discretionary
power to be given to them he was a
committed progressive and he had you
know come of age in the Progressive Era
had learned from progressives and so the
progressives are kind of the
intellectual if you're looking for
intellectual culprits you know I'd say
yeah the progress is but really it's
it's those who were influenced by
progressives in the in the New Deal
especially that this became a problem
for FDR himself because you may have
heard of something called the Brownlow
Commission which looked at how agencies
work and and the Brownlow Commission was
an attempt by Roosevelt to reclaim some
of the power that under the advice of
progressives he'd given away to the
administrative agencies because he was
all for this expert governance until he
realized what this means I don't do what
I say and so you know there there was
some tension even within the Roosevelt
administration over over over this
problem with that that's you know you
would
look for the the kind of architects
James Landis is a is a you know I really
get really excited about reading his
book the administrative process is how I
spend my time you know but but you know
that that's something I would recommend
you know if you're crazy enough to look
into this and then the the the sort of
intellectual arguments are there and in
the progresses themselves so that's a
quick and a quick answer it's quicker
you to get anyways thank you very much
you've been a great audience
you